et maintenant
ouais j'suis marc lavoine
ça va très bien dû être proféministes
vous parce que j'ai vu la façon dont
alonso vous a accueilli on s'aime
beaucoup assez ça je suis venu à la une
pour cela vous savez à la main à partir
marc lemoine c'est un mec qui sympa avec
les filles mais pas macho qui sait ça ah
je peux vous dire il est sexy grave
ah oui c'est vrai leur rebond c'est un
sexy boy
marc lavoine on vous a vu un petit peu
plus tôt dans la soirée sur le plateau
de la légende des voix une émission
voilà une émission animée par notre ami
n'est ce que je salue ici je partirai
ardisson est bien là tee shirt sur le
fil et je sais que tu as le live de la
carte
demain quartier que je conseille
effectivement ces bigots qui m'attirait
que ça c'est génial à ses mille et un
port un ne trouve pas encore on savait
alors donc vous étiez dans cette
émission se s'est bien passé rien elle
est bien mais ce nom oui elle marche
bien on la soutient que sur moi aussi
j'aime beaucoup naissent alors voilà
donc ça nous a mis l'eau à la bouche on
a entendu quelques chansons de vous mon
envie d'entendre plus donc c'est comment
on fait ici on fait didier
prévost
hélas
regard qui tue
elle est
m
oui
ce qui
qu'est ce que ces moeurs
quand on
c'est
vie
qui
en
g
mais sinon
blé
et vous
il
m
je
jour 3 m
j'attends
ce monde
non
jugez plutôt bien
go
aures ne sais pas
ici
prévenir
même si bas
oui
ouais bravo marc brun doré à l'or
le sanguinaire quelques soirs d'hiver
avec vous marc lavoine séquelles cette
fois doublé dans cette émission on
repasse toutes vos chansons et à chaque
fois on est vachement content donc tout
va bien je vais vous dire un truc c'est
que petit à petit chanson après chanson
ben vous installer au début comme ça
vous prenez juste pour un bon gars et
maintenant vous insérez un chanson
française comme un grand de la chanson
française
on voit bien quand on suit tout ça un
jean-luc c'est vrai je disais tout à
l'heure enfin je passe je pas vexé mais
c'est aussi une icône gay alors c'est
moi j'ai tous ses disques comme les
trois quarts des gays et il fait partie
patrimoine des fumigènes reggae de tous
les gars j'ai cherché ma qui va parler
de communautarisme mais ça va être chaud
alors dans le dernier album il y avait
une chanson qu'il beaucoup de succès
c'est donc un duo avec cristina marocco
que ça fait j'ai tout oublié
et puis il ya un autre duo si décidément
un qui marche encore mieux j'ai
l'impression si elle est claire keim ça
s'appelle je ne veux qu'elle est on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble